war schon richtig gut das ist richtig
gut und ich war kein band wir müssen
jetzt richtig klappen mit dem dreirad
hallo liebe willkommen zu einem neuen
format ich teste virale tik tok food
trends allerdings habe ich in diesem
video schon drei virale tik tok food
rezepte die sich nachzumachen lohnen das
ist kein trash oder so das leckere
rezepte und wenn ihr weitere rezepte
formieren sehen möchtet dann markiert
mich auf tick unter dem jeweiligen video
dann entsteht einfach das nächste video
wir fangen an mit tomato burgers und das
ist so ziemlich wir eingegangen weil in
amerika gibt es in and out burger und
die haben das kreiert und auch viktor
kassai danach gemacht es ist auch super
einfach und es ist low carb denn statt
burger bands werden hier tomaten benutzt
und dann geht's einfach weiter mit dem
petit käse ein bisschen zwiebeln salat
und das war es und ich probiere das
direkt mal aus und dafür dass autos so
was wie mcdonald's also nicht ganz so
krass aber ist schon sehr bekannt in den
autos auch länger bekannt ist heute wie
dieses zwölfter ist genau wie fünf geist
so eine art und ich werde euch alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben und natürlich auch
die mehrwerte unten in die infobox
schreiben die stadt jetzt auch direkten
das einzige was man diese wirklich
vorbereiten muss ist aber auch ein witz
rezept ist das fleisch bestehe jetzt
einfach meine sauberen hände ich ihm
gerne rindfleisch das relativ fertig ist
also 20 bis 25 prozent fettanteil
enthält und wäre das einfach ohne
gewürze erstmal in der pfanne von der
einen seite braten dann gebe ich salz
und pfeffer drauf und dann von der
andern seite und dann gebe ich noch
chatter käse um über
seit der ganze prozess hier in der
pfanne dauerte nur fünf minuten ich habe
aber noch mal den deckel drauf gegeben
damit meinen cherokee sie jetzt schön
schmilzt und jetzt gehts dann die
tomaten das ist ja unsere bürger band
ersatz und daher ja auch ein low carb
rezepte braucht dicker saftige
fleischtomaten die mich so westrich sind
ich habe nur ochsen herz tomaten
bekommen die heißen wirklich soll ich
auf der packung gelesen habe ich so
vorher auch noch nie gehört da werde ich
mir jetzt zwei schöne bands
rausschneiden und ein tipp von mir macht
es so dass sie auf jeden fall mit einem
küchenpapier die überschüssige
feuchtigkeit nochmal abnimmt
[Musik]
und jetzt natürlich den bürger einfach
belegen ihr könnt salat neben mario
alles worauf ihr lust habt aber macht es
am ende so dass ihr noch ein backpapier
oder in einem papier nochmal unten
drunter das ganze einwickelt weil das ja
das ist ziemlich flüssig und so kann es
einfach besser essen
also ich würd mal sagen ich weiß noch
mal rein oder dich haben wir müssen mal
richtig
der passt richtig gut war ich mir
richtig gut
ich bin richtig gut und ich war mister
können dann auch durch lee bowyer
sadistisch zu machen finde ich nicht
also wenn man tomatenmark sollte man das
machen wer keine tomatenmark wer ist es
am besten bleiben weil ich es richtig
brutal okay wenn man es weiter mit dem
nächsten selbstveränderung dann bereite
ich alles für unsere pasta chips vor
probleme nächster trend pasta chips und
das ist so der neueste trend auf tik tok
dafür werden ganz einfach nudeln al
dente gekocht und dann geben wie einige
jedes mal wenn er feuer
alle die das nicht haben nehmen
vielleicht einfach frittierfett ich
persönlich mag es im backofen am
liebsten und zu den nudeln die al dente
gekocht werden gehen wir einfach
olivenöl und gewürze und wer mag noch
ein bisschen käse ich breite dafür die
nudeln hier einfach auf einem backblech
aus dass wir das ganze mit gewürzen
aufgepeppt ihr könnt übrigens jede
nudelsorten nehmen die ihr möchtet es
gebe hier oregano dazu manche sagen auch
oregano jetzt eigentlich oregano oder
oregano ausgesprochen ich weiß es nicht
schreibt es nur in die kommentare wie
ihr es ausspricht da gibt es jetzt noch
ein bisschen chili dazu ich mag es nicht
so scharf deshalb ich möchte einfach ein
bisschen pepp da drin haben aber ich
übertreibe es nicht und paprikapulver
edelsüß danach kommen wir noch salz und
pfeffer dazu und olivenöl
[Musik]
alles schön verteilen und dann ab in den
ofen
so bei mir hat es jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad ober und
unterhitze 35 bis 40 minuten gebraucht
es kommt natürlich auch immer auf die
pasta sorten aber die müssten sich so
knackig anhören dann sind sie fertig wir
dürfen auf keinen fall gleichbleiben
[Musik]
so passt chips die müssen jetzt richtig
knacken
das ist unser schütze hatte die blue
chips also ich finde sie sehr lecker das
ist nicht mal was anderes als chips
diesen knackig wenn ihr die gut wird
dann sind sie wirklich ein toller snap
merkel mit deutsche ok schon sehr hart
dann habe ich so kurz an rohe nudeln
gedacht aber wenn man weiß sind
durchgegangen die sind einfach nur
knusprig ist wirklich sehr sehr lecker
ihr könnt das auch mit linsen
nudelmaschine probieren ganz wie ihr
möchtet ich fand's cool probiert's
unbedingt mal aus und schreibt mir auch
gerne generell zu allen rezepten solche
zweier feedback wenn es mal ausprobiert
hat und wir gehen jetzt rüber zum
nächsten tickt rezept okay das nächste
rezepte werdet ihr alle lieben da bin
ich mir sicher dass hamza nicht ob die
gestern noch beim filmabend gemacht weil
er kann so und zwar ist es am net toast
und da wird eigentlich erst mal nur
komplett vorbereitet aber man gibt die
post schon rein
im besten falle noch irgendwie käse
damit ist beim antritt auch schön
schmilzt und klappt das dann quasi
zusammen krieg schon richtig einsam und
ich sind alle total gut ausgedacht von
der macht genau das sieht einfach cool
aus und das ist eigentlich gar nicht so
das rezept ist auch eher so eine idee
natürlich kann jeder von alleine drauf
kommen aber man sieht es dann halt auch
tik tok und wird quasi daran erinnert
ich gebe jetzt in meine beschichtete
große fahne zuallererst etwas kokosfett
ich brate gerne in kokosfett an das ist
geschmacksneutral ihr könntet auch
mutter nehmen sondern habe ich hier
meine eier die werde ich jetzt hier
verquirlen und ihr könnt jetzt entweder
ganz klassisch salz dazugeben oder salz
und pfeffer ich werde mal rührei gewürze
zugeben so bietet sich halt gerade super
an
ein bisschen ruhiger wird rein jetzt
gebe ich die einmischung hier in meine
familie schon ordentlich auf temperatur
und wir gehen dann direkt die zwei
toastscheiben dazu ich muss nie weißt
aber für dieses rezept muss das
irgendwie sein könnte vollkorntoast oder
roggen nehmen
portos rhein direkt umdrehen
das ganze mit dem zweiten test auch noch
mal
[Musik]
so ich verteile jetzt noch ein bisschen
kitschig und cheddar käse
nachdem ihr das umgedreht und belegt
habt jetzt einfach nur noch die seiten
macht ihnen klappen so er habe gesehen
wie einfach das geht und vor allem
schnell
jetzt muss der katechese in drin noch
schmelzen und zu du braucht nur noch
selbst hitze also da braucht sich keine
sorgen machen
es geht jetzt immer noch ein bisschen
kokosöl in die fahrer dann ist auch
schön bräunt und gleich sehen wie der
käse herausspringt ich drehe das auch
immer mal wieder so fertig ist unser
motto ist und natürlich muss man ein
objekt in dreiecke schneiden
hallo sehr wohl klar dann springt
automatisch besser
[Musik]
ich bin ich passe einfach rein kiki zum
zweiten mal richtig rein
ganz ehrlich zu erweisen sie haben recht
bekommen haben wo es ist beste was mir
je passiert doch schreiben können wir ja
und war damit der heiraten ich mich da
rein legen also dann läuft es genau
richtig sagt rein linksschwenk so gut
mehrwerte schreibt unten rein falls ihr
euch interessieren wir nehmen einen
beeindrucken wollte zum frühstück gerade
macht das nach oder beeindruckt euch
selbst könnt euch richtig gut hansa com
wir können uns jetzt verabschiedet euch
an der stelle jetzt auch titel sich
verschluckt auf jeden fall hoffe ich
dass euch dieses format gefällt wie
gesagt freut uns auf tik tok und auf
instagram und aufsicht hat man mir von
dem premium content übrigen musst du
sagen es immer wieder weil wir brauchen
wirklich nicht auf jeder part bombe ist
gleiche und ihr seht ihr ein clip 1000
mann das ist richtiger premium content
also folgt uns da markiert nicht bei
solchen food trends und dann entsteht
wie gesagt das nächste video und
probiert diese drei rezepte bzw
inspirationen unbedingt aus bis zum
nächsten mal auf die gäste
[Musik]